as if they didn't have enough to battle
through the weather is biting
and Anna and Tony are back out in it
like everywhere else in the UK the
health system in Northeast Wales is
failing them and their patients I work
and live in the community so I know the
state of things sometimes if we're
queuing a hospital and all the
ambulances we've been queuing for most
of that day I worry that if my family or
friends you know need an ambulance I
know that we'd struggle to get one to
them within minutes we see just how
personal it can be
[Music]
the patient who's Fallen at home is one
of Tony's relatives you know this guy
hi Chris
it is
and it's like to just go in yeah
tell me oh wow are you doing that
all right now I've seen you it's just
got to me because I thought we can't go
on like this
recently Mervin and Christine had to
wait 16 hours for an ambulance and they
really didn't want to call again you
feel awful because it wasn't a matter of
life or death but it was still urgent
could then treat up that the next
strikes in Wales will be followed by
more ambulance workers in England
walking out overpay and this struggling
system it's not going to get any better
unless
the government takes some sort of action
to improve things so it's not what you
came into medicine for not at all no I
want to help people so at the moment I
don't think we're helping people the
best we can because the current
pressures that we're under
some of our lives and lashes they come
out of there in tears and it does get to
you it really does
don't work put the second plaster over a
very big wound it's not working at all
it's not working you can see how much
this team cares because they know that
what they've been providing here in
Wales and in the rest of the UK just
hasn't been good enough they are in
desperate need of radical change
the Welsh government says they are
taking steps to address the crisis but
on their 12-hour shift Anna and Tony
have only managed to see two patients
because their ambulance has become a
mobile waiting room this is not where
anyone wants to be
Tom Parmenter Sky News North Wales